- So it seems the Trump
Department of Justice
was up to even more shady
things then we knew about,
not only did the Trump
DOJ subpoena Twitter
to unmask the person who was behind
an anonymous Devin Nunes' parody account.
Not only did the Trump
DOJ get the phone records
for three reporters
for the Washington Post
who covered the FBI Russia Investigation.
But on top of that, the
Trump DOJ also secretly
obtained the phone and email records
for CNN Pentagon
correspondent, Barbara Starr.
The Trump DOJ procured emails
and phone records from 2017,
it's not at all clear why they
were after this information
or whether it was part
of an investigation,
but this is an incredibly
disturbing pattern
that is arising that
the Trump DOJ was going
after reporters for seemingly
no reason whatsoever.
But it's not like former President Trump
ever said that reporters
are the enemy of the people.
- I call the fake news the enemy
of the people and they are.
- Crap.
We'll see what happens
and if any of this ends up in court.